so actually we kind of we kind of like
jumped ahead because like kind of like
jumps into it normally what happens when
we when we have a guest on is we have
the guests introduce themselves and what
they do
just in case our audience doesn't know
uh what's uh but you are immediately
like what's your star
watch arcane watch out you all cancer
[Laughter]
so introduce me yeah
yeah what do you do let people know yeah
hi i'm lily pichu i go
i'm on youtube i stream sometimes i
voice act i make music
i like anime
so like how would you categorize
yourself as a content creator now are
you just like a bit of everything now
yeah i like to dabble in a little bit of
everything but not excel in like one
thing you know
[Music]
i mean you managed to stay online and i
best always get more and more popular
and relevant as you go yeah i think it's
uh
well i mean
i'm in a bit of a dip right now but you
know
i mean you're doing well you've been
around so long well like you've been on
the internet and you've been in like the
content creation space for like so
[ __ ] long
so long wait how like when did you start
what year was it literally like i feel
like over 10 years ago like i was like
19 or something i mean like
well i i started um voicing cartoons
anime you did fan dabs all right yeah
yeah
yeah i think
yeah early youtube fan updates were like
interesting yeah
because were you part of like the va
crowds back in the day when everyone was
like fan dubbing
yeah
i really did want a voice actor so i
never gave up on that dream yeah
thankfully got some roles oh yeah
yeah
um
yeah that's how i started
sick it's such a long such a such a long
journey and uh so
like so how did you like transition from
just doing anime stuff and then you
started like streaming and then you got
into offline tv how did like that happen
oh my gosh like how did it happen
like i just started making videos people
liked them and i started making and then
you know once you get more cloud and
viewers you can connect with other
people in the industry yeah yeah
um offline tv was like you know scarra
yes yes
and he's like no there's no way we can
get it it was really cute and it was a
real it was a cinderella shy and [ __ ]
i love scara
so i went on
and i think honestly a lot of why my
career has um
not died yet is because like the
connections yeah it's really hard for
one person to do everything by
themselves yeah because like either way
you know popularity fades right like
looks fade or whatever made you popular
face like things new trends come if you
can't see on top of it you're gonna fall
behind yeah so like definitely being
offline tv and like connecting with
other people collabing helps a lot yeah
like i would like to um like for example
remember the when the pandemic started
remember the whole among us craze yeah
of course that [ __ ] like made so many
people's careers oh yeah yeah yeah i
remember like corpse husband especially
like corpse husband went from like i
have never heard of this person before
he's like a superstar now yeah to like
to like k-pop levels
reading creepypastas to like selling
multi-platinum yeah yeah how the [ __ ] do
you do that and michael like likes to
listen to creepypasta before he goes to
sleep he used to listen to corpse
husbands
and now corpse is like
like a star
yeah like the superstar yeah now
especially in the content creation
it's like you never know who's gonna pop
off or who's gonna fall off like it's
very volatile scary i mean it is but i
guess that's just part of like the
career that we've chosen right it's it's
scary you wake up and you don't know if
you're gonna have a career next year
like well one year is like such a long
[ __ ] time in youtube space which is
why i find it impressive when anyone had
can be around for like as long as you
for example like the dinosaur
they've been around for a while i feel
that okay
when did you start 2007. wow
well yeah you're a dinosaur yeah i am if
you ever like watched anime back in the
day you just like recognized his voice
because you were like what were you
again like the fourth ever attitude i
was like the fourth annie trooper i
think yeah youtube should give you like
a little you know those like plaques
when you get 100k yeah annie
no don't give them
we don't need that
he didn't even get his silver play
button no i didn't because i got it they
got the 100k i think before they started
sending off silver play buttons
so i just never got them yeah
that's impressive i think i do think
anyone who's been on the space for like
that long
you've got to be doing something right
like yeah yeah you know what kind of
like take you so far so yeah so when i
started doing youtube it was because i
was getting annoyed with the voice
acting i was like i don't want to
[ __ ] keep fan dabbing other people's
stuff right i don't know if you were the
same kind of thing so we've all reached
that point yeah because you're like i'm
just tired of everyone taking their time
yeah everyone's like they've taken so
long you audition for something they're
like you got the part and then they're
like they never do anything or they make
you record stuff and you don't do it is
it was that like a similar thing for you
or you were just like i'm tired of
waiting for those projects yeah yeah
eventually you get tired and you want to
like do your own thing yeah yeah the
same for me yeah so you talked about
offline tv before and how that started
see we were there right at the beginning
near the beginning yes are you allowed
to talk about what like how that formed
at all well back then it was like chris
who's no longer with us scarra pokey
you know who's no longer with us poke i
think they just wanted to make like a
content creator group yeah right and it
was like
they invited me to live with them right
because it was like really weird at
first
at that time i just broken up with my
boyfriend like a really bad place and
yeah
i live with them and they're like all
right wake up at 5 a.m we're going
boxing and we're gonna make it into a
video and i'm like
what
it's just like it started out as a group
of friends who just wanted to make cool
videos yeah yeah yeah and then
eventually that like expanded to what it
is now i think even today we have
trouble like separating the friends from
the business because if you start off as
friends but you want to make it a
business like a full-time organization
you're going to hurt some feelings right
it's impossible yeah everyone has i
think that's why
we feel lucky that it's just the three
of us because i feel like when it gets
like a large group it's always hard to
manage everyone equally right
yeah yeah exactly
how was it like how is it living in a
house with like i guess your best
friends making content together does
that make it like harder to separate
friendship oh yeah for business he was
always intertwined we could not separate
it but it was fun because we would pop
into each other's streams whenever we
wanted it was easy to collaborate it was
like it was nice yeah yeah but i imagine
always having to be like on
it's probably tiring sometimes but it's
also like you know we liked each other
so yeah yeah
was it easy to like hang out as just
like a group of friends without feeling
like without feeling pressure to like
say make content about it or make
something out of it okay i did get
closer to a lot of people